i grew up in a suburb of milwaukee
wisconsin um
it was
a really idyllic place to grow up
i grew up with a mom and a dad
and an older sister it was a very
very loving home my mom in particular
was very nurturing and loving
and i was incredibly close with her
my dad traveled a lot for work
he and i weren't as close but
i had really
a beautiful childhood
up till about age 12
and i felt like
my mom really exemplified like a lot of
things that i've tried to
be as a mom myself um
but when i was 12 my dad
decided to leave my mom
and
it was very
sudden
they didn't fight
they had been a really
beautiful couple my mom had been a model
when she was younger my dad
was a star pitcher in high school
and
i guess nobody really expected
their marriage to end in divorce and
me and my sister certainly didn't expect
it either but he he left my mom which
was incredibly hard on her she had been
a stay-at-home mom
my whole childhood and she suddenly
found herself in the role of being
a single mom um
shortly after he left she
had found an ad in the back of our local
newspaper a personal ad
of a pastor who a self-proclaimed pastor
who was looking for a godly wife
and my family had not been particularly
religious at all
but apparently this had been a sort of
dream of my moms to
be a pastor's wife to
have a more religious uh life so she
answered
the ad
and
uh
very quickly got involved with this
again um self-styled pastor
of a really small
fundamentalist church
is what he called it fundamentalist
christian church
however it was
[Music]
it was it was not a church it was
really just a
small time cult um and
her involvement with him
had immediate changes
in our life she
said she had been
born again and
uh like immediately
there were rules imposed on her that
trickled down to me um
he
i had gone to public school
he
you know
immediately demanded i'd be sent to a
small christian school
as
as her time of dating him which lasted
five years from the time i was 12 to 17
went on
the rules would become
more arbitrary more
[Music]
have more to do with how you dressed who
you talked to
you couldn't celebrate holidays
he was
he imposed these rules her her uh
boyfriend at the time
she would marry him when i was 17. he
imposed these rules on her
um and i guess from my teenage years i
remember
seeing my mom going from being a very
vibrant and loving woman
to
a woman who is basically curled up in
the corner of
the couch every night in our living room
crying because
he had told her another way that she
failed to live up to his standards or
failed to be
the godly woman he wanted
meanwhile i would learn many years later
he was
using drugs
uh sleeping with his ex-wife sleeping
with multiple young women in the
congregation
um basically
living
a wild and degenerate life while
imposing these really strict rules on
his followers it was a small group and
in particular on my mom
and just the way he messed with her mind
was devastating to see and i felt like i
was living
in a nightmare
she came very close to marrying him
many times when i was a teen girl but
i felt like it was my responsibility to
sort of save her from him
and
i would you know cry and beg you know
don't marry him you know we can we can
go back to how things were we can live a
normal life
she
she was
sucked in she
he was a very charismatic person he was
very convincing
and like i said over my teen years it it
progressed it went from
being a very strict fundamentalist
christian
organization
to
you know dictating
not only how women dressed but how women
styled their hair
um
what color pens you could use to write
with
um just really
bizarre and arbitrary rules
he was a one-man show he ran this little
group
the way he wanted
um a huge part of
of
his
his rules was requiring that
his followers the members of the church
um
would go out and
street evangelize like all the time and
he would follow up on that and you had
to be doing that or you'd be kicked out
of the church
so my mom who was a single working mom
who would work all day at a very
boring
strenuous job to support me
and
my sister
would also like four nights a week
like go out to um either like our
airport or in front of a shopping mall
and um hand out religious tracks and
like this was absolutely required and
she was very
very concerned with pleasing him and
i was required to do this as well
which
i was a very
introverted
child so
and as a young teenage girl especially
this was like beyond mortifying to have
to go up to strangers and try to tell
them
why they were going to hell
but if i didn't my mom would be so like
disappointed in me and
um
i wanted to please her so i did this
um
it was awful it was embarrassing
um
and it was exhausting you know
and like i said these requirements would
just go up and up
um
so um
like i said i also tried to prevent her
from marrying him a lot as a teenage
girl i can
remember almost constantly like having a
stomach ache or feeling sick to my
stomach because of like the tension i
was holding in
another thing he required of his
followers was
to
open their homes to others and like take
in
random people so we often had
people that we didn't really know like
living in
our suburban home
and for a while there was a couple a
married couple there
and it was at a very intense time in my
mom's relationship with this man
and
i
i remember waking up one morning and
the man from this couple
standing over my bed
yelling at me that i was the only one
preventing my mom from entering this
godly marriage and
you know shouldn't i i was
a tool of the devil basically and if it
wasn't for me she'd be happily married
to this man
uh which was her like divine calling
and i just remember
like the feeling again as i was probably
15 or 16
in my little happy
teen girl bedroom in the suburbs you
know being yelled at
and i felt i was trying to save my mom
i don't know so much of my life
i feel like i just lived in a world
where
black was white and white was black
um
and
it's been
a hard thing to unlearn
so anyhow
from ages 12 to 17 on and off she dated
him
and eventually
he convinced her to marry him
when i was 17
and by that time
going to a little
fundamentalist christian school wasn't
good enough anymore i had to be pulled
out my senior year of high school to be
home schooled
and i was
forced to take classes like how to be a
submissive wife
you know how to how to keep a good home
and sit at a kitchen table with my mom
for my senior year of high school which
felt absolutely ridiculous
i also like had done very well in high
school
i came easily to me i got a's i would
have been valedictorian of my tiny
little
christian school class
but again i was pulled up for my senior
year um
i
my academic
claim to fame is that
i got an almost perfect score on my acts
and
even though i had no support at home i
could have gone to school anywhere i
wanted
um
like on the back of the acts you could
request that your transcripts be sent to
different colleges
i just i didn't have any hope so i think
i left that blank
but um a couple months after taking them
i actually got a letter from
oxford offering me
um a scholarship to come study english
literature there
and
i remember taking that letter home
[Music]
and
showing my mom well i guess i was at
home and showing my mom this letter and
she just looked at it like with kind of
an empty face and just said like
why would you want to go there like
you you just want to get married and
have kids like that's a woman's calling
you know why would you want to go
overseas it's like she didn't even
acknowledge
the school or anything or the the feet
that it was and
i didn't tell anyone i didn't have any
like
support outside of
of my family i had a few friends but
they were kind of going on their own
paths as well
and i felt
incredibly defeated and incredibly
trapped
so
instead of
going to oxford i went to
like a community college um
just to like something to do while i
tried to figure out like how to get out
of
the nightmare at home and
i i tried to do well at this little
college but again there were these
evangelism requirements on me
so i um
i couldn't i didn't have any time to do
homework because i was required to go
evangelize and again there was just
scorn and disdain if i said no i need to
stay home and like actually work on
school work
no you need to just you know you need to
go serve the lord and you know you're so
selfish that was a refrain i would hear
again and again
um
so like
i had just about had it at this point i
was 18 i knew
like
i could leave
i just didn't really have a plan how to
leave um
so
one day like i made up an excuse and
said i was not feeling well and they
went to either evangelism or bible study
and i packed up
everything i had
put in my car and i called my dad who
had not really been a part of my life as
a teenager and just said could i come
stay with him
and uh he said yes and that was
surprising to me so i moved in with my
dad for a little bit but he was kind of
living
the bachelor life and i could
tell he wasn't entirely comfortable with
me living with him
um
although he was very kind
um
so
when i was in high school i had been
part of this
pen pal exchange program
um
i had pen pals from a few different
places in the world um
including a
male pen pal a man from israel
and we had written for a number of years
and
we had exchanged pictures and
he was a good looking man
we
we flirted by letter this was all
pre-internet
we eventually exchanged phone numbers
and
i remember i would drive to gas stations
and sneak away and
make these long distance calls to this
this man in israel
um
and
somehow we came up with the plan that we
wanted to meet
he was arab israeli so it was very hard
for him to get a visa to the united
states at the time we ended up
somehow putting together this plan to
meet in montreal quebec
which was kind of absurd but we ended up
he flew there i told my dad this plan
and my dad
um
loved me unconditionally and
was sometimes more of a friend than a
dad um
but he said all right if that's what you
want to do i'll take you to the airport
i hope it goes well
so
with really no experience of the world
and having grown up incredibly sheltered
i
got an airplane and flew to montreal and
met my pen pal of a couple years
and
um i was 19 at the time he was 19 as
well and
um
i decided
you know we were in love
and
i
flew back once and like dropped out of
college and withdrew all my money from
the bank that i had earned with little
jobs as a teenager
and
flew back to montreal and we were going
to fly
back to israel with a plan that we were
going to marry each other
when i lived with him in montreal we
lived
in a ymca downtown montreal we had not a
lot of money
um there were things that
that he would do that stood out to me
that i kind of brushed off as
cultural differences you know he was
very very jealous um
and i just thought oh you know
he's an arab man you know they're
they're maybe a little more jealous
um
but in retrospect there were some
some tells that things were not going to
go well
um but i was very infatuated i was 19. i
had
big
indiana jones fantasies like i was going
to go on this great adventure and
i had read a lot as a child a lot and i
think
i always kind of lived in a little bit
of a fantasy world
i didn't know much about men in general
at all
and anyhow we flew to israel
and
he introduced me to his family as his
friend and
they were a muslim family so like
boyfriend girlfriend wasn't really
accepted
even though like they kind of knew
that we were
we had to be really careful in living
with the family
and
the people we lived in a little village
outside of nazareth israel
and the people were very very hospitable
very warm beautiful people
his family
however was very
unkind to me
they
did not like the fact that he had
brought an american woman there um
but
i actually ended up living there
three
excuse me three or four months
we
secretly went to a courthouse in
nazareth and got married
i had to convert on paper to islam
because there's no civil marriage in
israel
oh
i want to add one thing
when i was in montreal so i had you know
run away from home to go do this
um
i spoke with my mom one time
and she called me
to tell me um
you know what are you doing and she knew
who this this man was and i said i i
flew here to
to meet him
and i'm in love and
she said
her comment to me was
well jill i hope every single time you
look in the mirror
you're ashamed of who you are
and what you're doing and
i don't know that like stuck with me for
a really long time um
so
anyhow um
we
were married um
and
again it was it was a tense situation
with his family
um
but for the most part
things were still okay
um however we like would have to go
away from his family to be alone
or be intimate and we would drive in his
car
to this
olive orchard outside of a moshav or a
communal farm in israel close to where
he lived and
one night we drove out there and i don't
remember what the issue was at all um
but
he was really mad at me for something
some some
minor fights it might have been
something i was wearing i don't know
but
um
it was the first time he was violent
with me and
i remember we we got out of the car or
he like pulled me out of the car
and if you've ever been in israel at
night it's pitch black
and he um
he
he hit me across the face
and he drove away
and
i was miles from anything in the middle
of pitch dark
a night time in an olive orchard in
israel and i just remember thinking
like i felt
so
incredibly alone and
like i had made a really big mistake and
but now i was stuck
because he was the only one i knew and
i didn't know what to do i just
literally stood there i don't even know
how long um and he eventually
came back and got me but like things
cracked in my mind at that point like
my fantasy
was no fantasy anymore
um
then we um
we wanted to come back to america he
wanted to
build a life in america so
we flew back
ironically we ended up moving in with my
mom and her husband
there's a quote by robert frost
that home is the place that when you
have to go there they have to take you
in
it was kind of that kind of a situation
um
but
when we got back to america it was like
something let loose in him
um
and
things got
incredibly bad incredibly fast
um we only lived a couple months with my
mom before we got an apartment but while
we were there um
we lived in the basement he and i
and
she had like a random teenage girl
living there at the time like i said
they always took in
people um
and one night we got in an argument in
the basement
and
i still had some will left at this point
so there was
you know a little bit of yelling
and
in my basement
like with my mom and her husband
upstairs
like he hit me again like in the in the
mouth or nose and
i remember like running up the stairs
you know with blood
and running to my mom
and
just like an
ice cold response
this teen girl came over and she's like
did you hear what he did you know did
you see what he did to my mom
and
my mom looked at me
and said
well i heard you talking to him and you
didn't sound very submissive
and
like again this was just a moment in my
mind where like something broke and
i have a teenage daughter
i
i cannot imagine um
but she was totally under his
her husband's
thrall
uh she had essentially been brainwashed
by him and it was like no longer looking
in my mom's eyes it was like looking in
in vacant eyes and it
was yeah um
i knew there was no help to be found
there anymore at all
so we moved out and
we had our own
really small apartment
and
things got progressively worse very fast
i worked
he worked
i worked at a hotel front desk
and
i think in a abusive situations
it happened fast but it also happens
gradually where like you just kind of
excuse things at first and try to make
it seem normal in your mind but
for instance he
would take my paychecks i had no access
to the money that i earned
and
um
we were married for
um almost three years but it you know it
would be situations where i'd have to
beg for money for personal care items
um
he
wouldn't give me money to buy groceries
or food um i worked at a hotel they had
a continental breakfast and
for like two years
i lived off that food like
and i think the manager there i was a
good employee and a hard worker and the
manager there knew it and i think he
felt sorry for me and just kind of like
um but i was also really proud and i was
really ashamed to admit
that i had made a mistake in who i had
chosen to be with
um
and so i stayed quiet and pretended like
everything was normal
i also learned he was really
a sadistic person um
he would come home from work
and
like the first thing he would do is like
come sit next to me and hurt me
um
and he wasn't an idiot so he would do
things um
that wouldn't leave marks or be obvious
like i have messed up toes because he
would like twist
things um
just really like painful little sadistic
things
and
like to try to get a reaction out of me
and i would try to not react and it was
like this little sick game that he had
and he also started being really
verbally abusive
i had had a boyfriend in high school and
he was obsessed with the fact that i
wasn't a virgin when i married him
and he knew it
you know before he married me but every
day in my face you know just you're such
a [ __ ] you're such you know
uh
this and that um
so disgusting to me um sexually and this
was like my newlywed husband and i just
couldn't
i didn't have a like a framework for
that kind of like cruelty like i didn't
know i think i just dissociated a lot um
but
um
he
he occasionally would be more violent
and there were a few instances where i
you know would have to cover up marks
with makeup and things like that
um
about six months
into our marriage
i got pregnant
and
i
[Music]
i thought you know for sure this would
change things he would
you know now i'm pregnant now
now things will get better
um but he completely freaked out and he
said you know you gotta
you had to have an abortion right away
like and
again like i didn't have a framework for
this kind of
thought like and
i thought he was bluffing and
i made the appointment and
um
like it got to the day of the
appointment and it was an early morning
appointment and i remember him like
shaking me awake saying you know get
ready we had to go do this
and i was like are you serious like
i you know i still had thought at this
point it wasn't really a real thing
and
he got
very violent that morning
police actually came
like
so many women i
you know said nothing happened we were
just having an argument
um and
yeah he drove me
there and in like a state of complete
numbness
like i i went through with it and
i remember the worker there like asking
me you know did anyone
is anyone coercing you to do this
and i remember just looking at them
you know with just like dead eyes and
just saying no and
it was like an out-of-body experience
and
like i said he was very financially
abusive so i never had money for things
like
birth control like um health care um
basic human needs and um
this would become a pattern over the
course of our marriage
um
also like he
he said i was so like disgusting
that he like wouldn't ever
normally initiate sexual things with me
um
he would
wait until i fell asleep
and then basically rape me wake me up
by raping me
really
brutally
really
really violently and it led to
i was afraid to fall asleep
so
i was like in a constant state of
exhaustion
it made it really hard to work
and again like these little sadistic
things he would
do to my body
would kind of be his appetizer and turn
him on but it's like he couldn't admit
he actually wanted me sexually so he had
to wait until i fell asleep to do these
things and that created
problems throughout my life
um but over the course of the marriage
there were
the pregnancy and abortion situation was
played out a lot of times
like i
can't clearly
remember
a lot of it
like my brain just shut down
around that
but um
it was
yeah it was a devastating thing and the
more it went on
the more i became obsessed with wanting
a child
and like that would provide some sense
of magical relief
anyhow
i was working at this hotel
i read a lot while i was there it was a
new hotel
um
so it was very dead like no not a lot of
customers
um
and like i i just i don't know like
reading books about other people's
lives and suffering like somehow like
saved my mind during that time like
made me feel because i was very isolated
and it made me feel less so
there was one friend
who
checked on me a few times
um
a boy i had gone to high school with he
was um
he was a senior when i was a freshman
but we were we were good friends and he
would occasionally check on me although
if he checked on me by calling me when i
was at home
all hell would break loose with my
my husband
he showed up at my work at the hotel
once he found out where i worked from my
mom i think
and
he knew something was wrong
and
somehow i got the courage to
like meet him for a lunch and i confided
in him
a little bit of what was going on at
home i couldn't even
express
[Music]
close to
all of what it was
but
he he basically said
i'm getting you out of there um
and
he
and my dad again like i didn't tell my
dad any of this my dad had no idea
what was going on i i didn't talk to
anyone when you're
in this kind of situation at least for
me like i just stopped talking to people
friends everyone um
but anyhow
um
through
this friend's support and help
uh he and his buddy and my dad
came to the little hellish apartment
that i lived in right after my husband
had gone to work
and in about an hour packed up my very
few belongings and
drove me
i got an apartment right by where my
my dad lived
and
i never
i never looked back um
and
i filed for
divorce
um and i make this sound like a an easy
process but
i should say like i was
i was in such bad like shape
psychologically when i left him that i
remember like
i couldn't
i couldn't talk to someone in a store i
couldn't
order a coffee i couldn't order food
i was wrecked i was just completely
wrecked
i actually had like a huge
uh like autoimmune flare-up where like i
couldn't
walk for a few months i was like 21
and like
i i couldn't walk i had to use a walker
like they couldn't ever really explain
to me what was going on with my body but
i think it was just a complete
stress response um
anyhow
so i got out of there
so when i left um
my first husband
he knew that
my mom's cult religion did not believe
in divorce
and he knew he would find
sympathy there he was a very conniving
person and he went to my mom and
had this sob story of your daughter left
me you know and you know i don't know
why
and um
she
took him in and he actually moved back
in with them
and she would
my mom would show up with him
at our court hearings
um
both of them carrying bibles because he
had now converted to christianity and
not only that but after our divorce was
done
my mom
um
like helped him basically choose a new
wife which was another young lady that
was involved in
in the cult
and
yeah
i did my mom's home at that time as well
like i was told i don't think i saw it
but like my senior picture was taken
down from the wall and that girl's
picture was put up that was like her new
her new daughter
um
so yeah
anyhow
so
this friend who had moved me out
was kind to me
and to me represented
safety
and
he
um
came from what i thought was a really
solid christian family
and
like a few months later
i
i was marrying him and
like
you know i didn't know anything so i
thought
he was young too
um
i hadn't
like i was in no shape to get married
clearly um
our first year of marriage was
incredibly rough i would cry every
single day he didn't know what to do you
know or why
um
but
um
yeah like
it
he still represented safety and he did
the best he could
as a man in his young 20s i think he
also came from a fundamentalist
christian background
and things were better
in a way
but i was still holding on to this like
paradigm
that
that you know this fundamentalist
interpretation of christianity was
the right way and anything that that
veered away from that was wrong
um and
like coming out of an abusive
an incredibly abusive marriage and
situation
and still like having
you know we were church going still
having those those beliefs somewhat
watered down it wasn't
as
extreme as the cult my mom was in
but you know still being told you know a
woman's role is to be submissive and to
be quiet and
[Music]
this and that like i can't explain how
profoundly damaging that is to someone
who
comes from any type of abuse and
um
the other thing like the good christian
people that i would talk to
basically told me
basically my whole life to be quiet
about this you know like don't talk
about it just pretend it didn't happen
in particular in particular around the
abortions i had been
forced to have like i
was i bore so much guilt over that and
so much shame
um
like i was scared to mention that around
good christian ladies because
like just
that's like the unforgivable sin um
it was
so i held a lot inside
and
again like i wanted to have a child and
a year into our marriage i did i
like my body had been through so much
that like a doctor had actually told me
i probably could not get pregnant
but i did and i
i had my oldest son and
i was lost in a world of love for him it
was
i completely threw myself into being a
mom
i had three children in my 20s um
and
i
wanted to live out this
this good life this good christian life
um
so like i actually homeschooled my kids
till they were in fifth or sixth grade
which was actually a beautiful
experience i love teaching my kids
they were my world i would take them
places
every single day
but there was always like this
this void and this like darkness in me
that i felt like i didn't fit anywhere
because of things that had happened in
the past
i think as my children got older
i was
i had more time
with myself um
i was a stay-at-home mom
and
as their teenagers and start to need you
less i think a lot of these repressed
trauma issues really like
were starting to come to the surface um
and
uh
my husband and i had grown apart he was
really
involved in his business
and
after
17 years of marriage
i
i was dreading him coming home
and i didn't want
to feel that way i didn't want that to
be my life
so
i made the decision to leave the
marriage
ends of marriages aren't pretty
and
it was
particularly difficult we never had a
lot of
money or financial resources i hadn't
worked
since i was like a teenager or a very
young adult
but i i worked three jobs to
save money
to move out because i knew that if i
didn't leave the marriage
it would never end and it was an
incredibly difficult decision
but i moved out and um
i
i worked
and
i
found love and
i
um
i started to meet
good people
that
when i told them certain parts of this
story
didn't judge me and didn't
didn't condemn me and listened and
understood
and
like that
a handful of good friends that came into
my life like in the last four years
were transformative
to me like in getting my mind out of
this paradigm that i was still somehow
breaking all these
laws of god by having a voice by
speaking
um
i had a friend
tell me you know
when i told them some things about my
past you know why don't you try going to
school like why don't you it's not too
late you could try that
so like i
um
enrolled in college and
i
i'm still a full-time student i got to
go to school um
but
like
it wasn't easy like i still struggle
with
like
practical things sometimes
but
um
yeah so
i was going to school i had
just
made a transition to
get an apartment big enough so that my
kids could come stay with me sometimes
which was a really big deal
and things were going fairly well for me
um
and
then
suddenly my dad died he
had likely a sudden heart attack
and this happened in late 2019 and
my dad and i over my adult life had
gotten closer and closer he
was my support system he was my go-to
he was really
the only embodiment of like
unconditional love that i ever had um
and um
i had always made a joke that
if my dad ever dies i'm going to lose my
mind
what i didn't expect to happen was i
actually
had that happen
so he
he died and i became
extremely depressed i started to
struggle with
school work
i quit my job
i was you know in a relationship that
was a little uncertain and
i
i became more and more depressed but
like over the course of a week
uh this was a few months after he died
the depression turned to
like extreme paranoia
and like all of a sudden
i was having these like paranoid
thoughts that you know
people could see my thoughts people
could see
what i was writing i've written all my
life and
i've often
like i i journal and i've often felt
well my mom
once found my journal and like
just totally shamed me for everything i
wrote and like i've often felt really
like ashamed of what i write
um
but
anyhow like i i had these like
paranoid delusional thoughts and then
like in the course of
a night
uh
it turned on it like i went into a
different world i
stepped out of this world
into a delusional world and
um
friends were you know incredibly
concerned about me i wouldn't go back to
my apartment i thought my apartment was
being watched all the time i accused
loved ones and friends of you know
terrible things
i thought my children
were not really my children the
delusions became more profound over time
i lived in my car for a little while
but the culmination of that i eventually
um
got a studio apartment with nothing on
the walls just like a white studio
apartment i unpacked nothing there i had
like a bare mattress
language and words like all seemed
really menacing to me um so i just
wanted nothing i wanted blankness
um and i completely like stopped talking
to everyone
um
i think
kids and family assumed i was on drugs
um
which i wasn't and
i would spend
like
15 hours a day standing in that
apartment staring at the wall
because i thought i had to
when you're delusional
you don't know you're delusional it's
really hard to explain
but my biggest delusions were that i was
going to go blind
and that everyone was like part of a
hive mind except me
so in order to keep my sight i had to
stand and stare at this wall
and
like i wouldn't even allow myself to sit
and like all these rules came up my
whole life like i think had been
trying to follow rules and then like
when i
lost my mind for this period it was like
i enacted all these severe rules on
myself
um
so like yeah i'd stand i didn't think i
was allowed to eat i
stopped eating um
i went like 28 days at one point without
eating
i um
i would go four or five days without
drinking and then just barely take sips
of water
um i lost like
almost a third of my body weight i was
emaciated um
and
again like i wasn't talking to anyone
nobody knew and
i eventually became so afraid
that i was going to go blind that i
was afraid of going blind in this
apartment alone i wanted to see my kids
faces one more time even though i didn't
really believe they were
my kids um i just wanted to see their
faces
so
um
the psychosis like culminated
like maybe the worst experience during
that time was
i
set out walking one night like in
in my city in milwaukee
and
um
i was being talked to by
i guess you could say voices cars were
talking to me and telling me to do
things
i remember like
being given challenges
to like walk backwards into traffic
with my eyes shut
and like the goal was to get hit so i
could die and like end this
um but it was like
it was weird because i guess in a sense
i was suicidal but it was more like
delusionally based and like a game
almost
um
i walked for like 13 hours one night
that night and
again and again doing these challenges i
think i caused like a minor car accident
one time like it was it was really bad
um
but like as as daylight broke
the like last challenge because i wasn't
i wasn't killing myself was
climb a fence to the freeway and get
down there and do it there because
that'll work
um
and so like severely
emaciated and severely delusional like i
um
like at seven in the morning climbed
this fence
and
like i was really weak so it was really
hard to get over this chain-link fence
um
but these two
women
mother and daughter uh pulled up
and
saw me and it was like 30 degrees out i
had a stopping wet winter coats it was
also raining
and they held onto the edge of that coat
and called the police
and i fought them
and
um
like they basically saved my life
and i don't know that was
i think the thing that i learned going
through that time
was like for me i think that psychosis
was my way of dealing with a lifetime of
or my mind's way of dealing with a
lifetime of like suppressed trauma
um
it's also like interesting and i know
like
when you
when you present as crazy to the world
when you're a silent emaciated dirty
because i also didn't think i was
allowed to wash like woman walking the
streets people don't see you
people pre
pretend you're not there
and
um
it's interesting because i had such kind
people like that pull me down from from
the fence but like i was taken to the er
of course and i remember i was silent
and unresponsive and very stiff and they
had to like cut my clothes off
and i remember
like the er nurses like talking about me
like i wasn't there like laughing
at like how my how dirty i was and my
body
and it's just like
i wish people could know that
like people who are crazy still can hear
you they're still people they still know
what you're saying i never lost my
intelligence but i had people talk to me
like
you know
like i was profoundly mentally disabled
and
yeah like people just don't see you on
the on the bus you know oh another thing
like when during this time of psychosis
i had been
you know i had been abused through food
so i starved myself
i had been abused financially so the
like little money i had
like to live off of i gave away to
anyone and everyone like i
i sold my car um like i didn't think i
was allowed to have a car i thought i
was supposed to walk everywhere
i don't know the
the human mind is just really
interesting to me
um
it's like all the things
i had suffered i like did to myself
worse it's hard to explain
um
but
um
like as quickly as that came on and as
long as it lasted
um
it went away um
and
through
like the love of a few people and
support
and
like some basic kindness
i came out of that
and
um obviously like it caused a lot of
damage
in my life that i'm still trying to
repair but
i think the the main thing i've learned
is
like real love doesn't have conditions
on it
real love doesn't require adherence to
rules
and like that
was something
i had to like deprogram from my whole
life and still am
all right jill thank you so much for
sharing your story thank you
good luck with everything thanks thank
you
you